salut je voudrais vous parler
aujourd'hui de quelque chose d'important
pour la rigueur intellectuelle mais
aussi pour la communication et la paix
des foyers on va diviser sa en deux
vidéos sinon ce serait trop long
un jour j'ai envoyé un mail un chercheur
en philo pour lui poser des questions
sur un sujet dont il est devenu une
sorte de spécialité dans sa réponse
il m'a reproché de manquer de charité
herméneutique j'étais à la fois content
et troublée content parce que comme lui
je trouve ça très important de faire
preuve de charité herméneutique c'est
quelque chose auquel je tiens beaucoup
troublé parce que je ne pensais pas
qu'un jour on me ferais le reproche d'en
manquer mais en relisant j'ai conclu
qu'il s'agissait d'un malentendu ça m'a
rassuré mais au fait c'est quoi la
charité un mimétique avant d'avoir sa
spécifiquement je veux faire un petit
détour par l'argument dit de l'homme de
paille ou straumann en engrais un homme
de paille c'est une présentation
caricature et de la position adverse
pour mieux l'attaquer
cette caricature peut être volontaire ou
involontaire j'ai d'emblée été victime
de plusieurs hommes de paille avec les
premières vidéos de cette chaîne par
exemple dans celle intitulée les niveaux
de complicité affective
c'est arrivé deux fois d'abord parce que
dans cette vidéo
j'interroge le fait de ressentir de la
joie quand on reçoit une bonne note à
l'école je n'entre pas dans les détails
de l'argument ici mais l'homme de paille
qui m'a été lancée consistait à faire
comme si je n'y ai tout intérêt au
principe de notation en général comme si
je refusais à la note sa fonction
pédagogique qui est d'indiquer si le
travail était compris on pourrait tout à
fait discuter des limites du principe de
notation je ne suis d'ailleurs pas sûr
de vouloir le défendre
mais ce n'est pas le problème le
problème c'est que je n'ai rien dit de
tel
dans la vidéo cet exemple sur la note
fait partie d'une démonstration plus
large qui vise à mettre en lumière le
caractère potentiellement aliénant des
affects symbolique en les opposant à des
insectes qui reposerait davantage sur
des sensations
cette fois l'homme de paille c'était
uniquement composé de sensations c'est
assez classique toute pensée qui annonce
il faudrait faire un peu moins de x est
un peu plus d y est une proie facile
pour une réponse du type ne peut pas
gérer la totalité des xe où on ne peut
pas se contenter de y cet homme de
paille et la réduction d'une pensée qui
se veut spectrale et une dimension
binaire un peu comme passer de la 3d à
la 2d pourquoi fait-on ce type de
réduction j'ai une idée mais ce n'est
que mon idée il faudra que je vais
développer ailleurs je vous la présente
rapidement tout de même comme teaser de
la vidéo qui lui sera consacré une
évaluation spectrale n'est pas agréable
à adopter parce qu'elle équivaut à une
promesse de fatigue je veux dire tout
bêtement que si on annonce à quelqu'un
dans cette situation tu ne pourras pas
te contenter de choisir entre deux
options à henan a juste ou injuste vrai
ou faux je prends où je jette
il faudra que tu essayes consciemment de
produire une évaluation nuancée qu'on
pourrait placer sur inspectent la
personne comprend tout de suite que cela
requiert un travail et cérébrales
relativement épuisant la loi du moindre
effort étant ce qu'elle est on a tous
tendance à refuser l'attitude qui
demande du boulot je prends mes propres
arguments en exemple parce que ça révèle
que les gens qui oppose des hommes de
paille ne sont pas forcément des
adversaires malhonnêtes qui veulent vous
abattre et vous humilier en place
publique en l'occurrence ce sont des
amis qui spontanément
malgré leur bienveillance sincères sont
conduits à être injuste
intellectuellement on fait tout ça si
les hommes de paille sont si fréquents
c'est peut-être surtout parce qu'il est
très facile d'en produire
accidentellement à cause d'une simple
incompréhension de la thèse adverse
jusqu'à preuve du contraire personne ne
peut lire dans notre esprit n'oublions
pas que notre propre thèse nous paraît
toujours beaucoup plus clair qu aux
autres pourquoi on refuse une thèse
peut-être parce qu'on la trouve peu
vraisemblable ou parce qu'on pense
qu'elle promeut des idéaux dangereux sur
le plan politique parfois parce qu'on a
le sentiment que quelque chose cloche ce
sentiment que quelque chose cloche peut
provoquer un refus spontanée et il faut
interroger ce refus il est encore
possible que ce soit à cause de failles
dans le raisonnement qu'on n'arrive pas
à percevoir clairement donc on prend le
temps d'analyser à tête reposée on
s'empêche de conques l'autre vide la
discussion sera d'autant plus efficace
qu'on sera capable de projets le rouage
du raisonnement adverse qui nous embête
il faut se demander si ce n'est pas pour
des raisons personnelles
peut-être qu'on aime parce que la
théorie implique à cause de nos
croyances relatives au monde
dans ce cas il faut se demander si on
défend nos croyances pour des bonnes
raisons
partout c'est le cas parfois non et puis
comme on disait cela arrive plus souvent
qu'on ne pense
il arrive que l'on refuse une thèse
parce qu'elle implique une production
importante des phares cérébrale quand on
nous présente une manière de penser
qu'ils demandent du travail soit parce
qu'il s'agit de tester nos propres
croyances méthodes soit parce que cela
consiste à produire des années ou encore
parce que c'est la demande de résister
activement une tendance comme celle de
conclure alors on peut avoir tendance à
refuser la proposition
je crois qu'il serait sain de faire une
petite introspection au moment où l'on
refuse quelque chose pour interroger la
source de ce refus il faut garder à
l'esprit que peut-être il nous manque
des informations pour comprendre la
thèse le contraire de l'homme de paille
c'est ce qu'on appelle faire un homme de
fer stillman en anglais vous représentez
la thèse adverse sous son meilleur jour
avec le plus de rigueur possible
comme pour essayé d'affronter sa version
sous stéroïdes de sorte que si vous
arrivez à contredire cette version super
balèze il y a une meilleure chance que
votre argument soit pertinent et bien la
charité en monétique ça ressemble à
l'homme de fer mais c'est encore plus
généreux en quelque sorte comme si
l'homme d'affaires était lui-même sous
stéroïdes ces latitudes
lorsqu'on fait face à un discours qui
consiste à donner toute sa chance à la
formulation choisie par l'interlocuteur
ça veut dire quoi donner toute sa chance
d'abord ne jamais perdre de vue qu'on ne
projette pas tous les mêmes connotation
aux mots qu'on emploie donc déjà cela
revient à se dire que l'interprétation
spontané que j'ai fait de la phrase
n'est pas la seule possible et qu'il ya
peu de chance que ma compréhension
spontanée de la phrase prononcée par
mois interlocuteur soit exactement celle
qu'il avait en tête
c'est le premier point de la charité
herméneutique un appel à la prudence
une fois qu'on a retenue cela que
fait-on eh bien on passe en revue comme
dans un catalogue mentale toutes les
significations possibles de chaque mot
pris séparément et commence en formant
une phrase et on choisit les versions
les plus fines les plus subtils ou tout
simplement celle qui fonde la phrase un
support de réflexion et non un mur
exemple quelqu'un dit sans pitié l'autre
pour y répondre
mais pourquoi un tel mépris parce que le
premier sens qui vient à l'esprit c'est
vide et de condescendance mais un petit
tour dans le catalogue mental nous
rappelle que la pitié renvoie d'abord
aux sentiments de compassion faire pitié
c'est inspiré un tel sentiment et le
désir de vouloir soulager ses peines
la définition du larousse est
intéressante plus ou moins réels et
parfois méprisante révèle bien que
l'interprétation est ouverte
phrase change alors radicalement de
tonalité d'un côté je les méprise de
l'autre je souffre pour eux et
j'aimerais les libérer cette douleur
quand on se sent en désaccord avec une
phrase exprimé par autrui
on pourrait commencer par se demander si
les mots employés ont d'autre sens que
ceux que j'ai projeté spontanément c'est
le deuxième point de la charité
amniotique un appel à notre imagination
on pourrait donc dire que d'une certaine
façon faire preuve de charité
herméneutique c'est produire soi-même
les conditions de possibilité de
pertinence de la phrase s'est trouvé en
quel sens la phrase est raisonnable
intelligente fine au risque de me faire
insulter je dirais que si les
philosophes continentaux peuvent manquer
de rigueur et de clarté argumentative
les philosophe de tradition analytique
quant à eux peuvent manquer de charité
herméneutique je ne dis pas ça pour
commencer un clash mais pour donner un
exemple
examinons la première information sur la
philosophie continentale en l'occurrence
être charitable ce serait se poser
plusieurs questions comme ac l énoncé de
la philosophie continentale cela peut-il
renvoyer quelles exigences de clarté et
de rigueur faut-il adopter pour que
leurs reproches formulés à l'encontre de
la philosophie continentale ne semble
pas injuste ou déplacés quelles attentes
relatives au projet philosophique
faut-il revendiquer pour assumer un tel
reproche leur reproche-t-il léger ou
appuyer quelle échelle victime celle
tout simplement comprendre
en quel sens on peut légitimement leur
reprocher un manque de rigueur et de
clarté ce qui peut revenir à se demander
peut-on imaginer au moins un cas où la
formulation de la pensée était si peu
rigoureuse qu'on ne pouvait en être côté
le potentiel philosophique remarquer que
j'ai pris un exemple super meta ici
parce que le sous texte de cette
formulation c'est peut-on faire
légitimement se reproche même en ayant
fait preuve de la meilleure volonté en
termes de charité herméneutique noter
qu'on pourrait s'occuper de l'autre
versant de la phrase ça suppose de se
demander
peut-on imaginer au moins un débat où
une discussion où une forme de rigidité
interprétative de la part d'un ou d'une
philosophe de tradition analytique
aurait empêché d'accéder au potentiel
philosophique d'une pensée bon là c'est
un exemple très mesuré mais ça me semble
vraiment important pour ce qui est des
énoncés politique mettons que quelqu'un
dise le port du voile islamique peut
être une revendication féministe
on pourrait imaginer que cette
affirmation en a priori en contradiction
avec vos idées de ce qu'implique d'une
part le port du voile islamique et
d'autres pas
le concept de féminisme on pourrait
commencer par envoyer au théorème de
bayes la vidéo arrive bientôt pour
invités à évaluer le degré de certitude
on se demanderait alors à quel point
fait confiance à la représentation que
je me fais de ce que c'est que porter le
voile
est-ce que je pense maîtriser la
totalité des implications du concept de
féminisme et je fais une place
consciente pour des hypothèses inconnus
qui pourraient assouplir voir changer
les croyances relatives à la question du
féminisme et ou du voile quel
pourcentage de la littérature féministe
et jules cela revient donc à se demander
en bon bézian qu'elle ait la cote chez
les bookmakers du match qui oppose
l'hypothèse à et l'hypothèse nana avec à
je connais suffisamment le féminisme
pour me prononcer sur ce qu'il peut ou
non contenir et nana je ne connais pas
suffisamment le féminisme pour me
prononcer sur ce qu'il peut ou non
contenir mais ça on pourrait dire que
cette attitude rationnelle c'est le
minimum
la charité harmonie tic ce serait aller
un peu plus loin et se demander et je
fais l'effort d'imaginer des conditions
sémantique qui rendrait compatible voile
d'un côté et féminisme de l'autre et je
fais l'effort d'imaginer ce qu'il faut
que ces concepts 10 pour pouvoir
fonctionner ensemble sans produire de
contradictions
la charité un magnifique c'est ça jouer
et tordre les mots pour trouver un sens
qu'on accepterait tordre les mots pour
rejeter ces l'homme de paille
attention je dis qu'on accepterait je ne
veux pas dire qu'on adopterait ne s'agit
pas de se forcer à être d'accord mais de
se donner les moyens de considérer la
position adverse sans mépris sans
condescendance en faire un point de vue
qui nous paraît légitime même si on
continue de s'y opposer
ce qui a deux vertus d'abord c'est
mettre à l'épreuve nos croyances notre
propre thèse à la limite peu importe si
c'est ce que l'autre a voulu dire au
moins on a élargi notre capacité
d'interprétation et cela peut nourrir
notre réflexion
ensuite c'est se donner une chance de
comprendre ce qui nous oppose à l'autre
la raison du conflit
là où les points de vue se confrontent
plus on comprend pourquoi n'entend pas
plus on sera capable de gérer ce conflit
pour affirmer que le port du voile n'est
pas compatible avec un geste féministe
il ferait donc avoir une connaissance
extrêmement pointue de tout ce que peut
recouvrir le féminisme voir être capable
d'en dégager un noyau d'irréductibles si
c'est possible
bonne chance
ce qui n'empêche évidemment personne ne
dira le port du voile n'est pas
compatible avec le féminisme que je
défends parce que et ça c'est un début
bien plus prometteur pour une discussion
notamment parce que c'est un langage a
précisé ce qu'on défend pourquoi on le
défend certains seront peut-être compter
de répondre mais alors il n'y a plus
moyen de refuser une thèse cela suppose
de tout accepter
ce n'est pas vrai ça c'est un homme de
paille gagner en souplesse ne veut pas
dire perdre toute structure et comprend
ne veut pas dire être d'accord on peut
trouver des points de rupture
par exemple en philosophie on pose la
question de savoir si le déterminisme
est compatible avec le libre arbitre
c'est une question de logique si nos
actions sont entièrement déterminés
alors peut-on encore dire que nos
décisions sont libres on distingue d'une
part les compatibilités ceux qui pensent
qu'on peut défendre l'existence du libre
arbitre
tout en acceptant les prémices
déterministe des non compatibilité
d'autre part ceux qui pensent que si on
tient pauvres hères l'hypothèse
déterministe alors on ne peut pas
défendre l'existence d'un libre arbitre
je reconnais que ma charité amagnétique
trouve ici un point de rupture
du peu que j'ai compris la position
compatibilité suppose une transformation
du concept de libre arbitre que je ne
veux pas accepter parce qu'elle jette ce
qui me semble être la connotation la
plus importante de l'idée à savoir la
croyance selon laquelle je suis maître
de certaines décisions dans ma vie
jusqu'à ce qu'on démontre le contraire
je ne vois pas l'intérêt de garder le
concept de libre arbitre
si ça n'implique pas cette idée sa force
à mettre au clair ses convictions il
faut donc ouvrir une discussion sur
notre rapport au concept de libre
arbitre
attention j'ai bien conscience que ce
débat est plus compliqué plein d'enjeux
m'échappe forcément je ne me prononce
pas vraiment sur la question l'intérêt
de cet exemple c'est simplement de dire
qu'il est possible de défendre et
d'expliquer les limites que l'on pose à
l'adaptabilité des concepts voilà pour
le premier volet de cette vidéo en deux
parties la prochaine fois on monte d'un
cran